a lot of people think they need to have
some novel idea to start a business one
in my opinion the best way to start a
business is just look at what everyone
else is doing and just try and do it
better there's obvious holes like if
you've gotten your dry cleaning it's
like can I do this in half the time like
well cool then I've got advantages what
are things that I already know how to do
or I have past experience in what things
because I have past experience I know
that other people struggle with and then
I will solve that specific problem and
it could also be a problem that other
people solve too you just try and do a
little bit better it's just not rocket
science you're still trading time for
dollars but the point is that you're
trading that time for money in order to
learn not to earn so the vast majority
of your income is coming in the form of
Education rather than earning